[MUSIC PLAYING]
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
APRAJITA JAIN: Good
morning, everyone.
And good evening to everyone
who's joining us over
live stream from
Europe and India.
My name is Aprajita Jain.
I'm an Executive Summits
Evangelist at Google.
But more importantly, I live,
breathe, and sleep Bollywood.
When I found out a few weeks
ago that Arjun Rampal is going
to be joining us here at
Google and sitting right here
next to me in this very chair
I started hyperventilating.
All good now.
I meditated last night.
Arjun Rampal, a National
Film Award winner, a model,
an actor, a producer, and the
breaker of many a girl's heart,
is here today at
Google to talk to us
about his career, his movies,
his social engagements,
his businesses, and
most importantly
about the upcoming movie that he
produced and acted in, "Daddy."
Let's play a teaser
clip of that movie.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[SPEAKING HINDI]
[END PLAYBACK]
APRAJITA JAIN: Let's play a
teaser clip of the movie again.
That's all right.
Technical issues,
Google-- synonyms.
Should we queue it up later?
Fantastic.
No problem.
So in the meanwhile,
everyone please join me
in welcoming none other
than Arjun Rampal.
[APPLAUSE]
ARJUN RAMPAL: Hello.
Hello, hello.
Hi.
Thank you.
APRAJITA JAIN: Welcome, Arjun.
ARJUN RAMPAL: Thank you.
Hello.
How's everybody doing?
Do I sit there?
APRAJITA JAIN: Yes.
ARJUN RAMPAL: OK, cool.
OK, I can see all of you now.
APRAJITA JAIN: See, you have
both your sides are pretty.
For me, it's only one side.
So I had to pick this.
ARJUN RAMPAL: Pretty?
APRAJITA JAIN: Yeah.
Good looking.
ARJUN RAMPAL: Oh.
That's not a nice thing
to say to a guy-- pretty.
OK.
Oh, it's wonderful to be here.
So thank you.
Thank you for coming
early in the morning.
Google was insisting
that I have a nice round
tour of all the headquarters,
so I went to the wrong campus
and to the wrong campas
and now finally I'm here.
But it's great to be here.
APRAJITA JAIN: Well,
finally, welcome to Google.
We are thrilled
to have you here.
ARJUN RAMPAL: No, it's
wonderful to be here.
APRAJITA JAIN: As
you can see, there's
many Googlers in
the audience live.
But we also have many of
your fans watching you
from around the globe on
YouTube live right now.
ARJUN RAMPAL: Yeah, I know.
So hello to all
of them watching.
APRAJITA JAIN: And
I know they're all
eager to hear from you,
so we'll jump right in.
And my first question
for you, Arjun,
is you had been in the
Bay Area a few weeks ago.
You came to promote
something which we'll
talk about in just a minute.
But what are your
impressions of the Bay Area?
And what does this place
tell you about-- do you ever
want to make a movie out here?
ARJUN RAMPAL: You know, actually
I was just thinking that,
because I was in this
small, little hotel.
And it was so lonely.
And I was just sitting there.
And there were all these people
with backpacks and, you know,
young kids just moving
around that place.
And I'm thinking,
OK, who's that guy?
I wonder what app he's making.
And I wonder what
app he's making.
he's coming up with.
So you know, you don't know
what's really going on there,
because it is--
it's got a nice, calm energy.
And I think it
kind of brings you
a certain amount of solutude,
where you can really
sit and think.
And I've got a lot to
think actually yesterday,
so I'm glad I was here.
And I would love to come
back and visit and explore.
And if I could make a
movie here, it'd be great.
Yeah.
But if any of you have a
nice app I can invest in,
please let me know
before I leave.
APRAJITA JAIN: I'm sure there
will be plenty of ideas here.
OK, so all political
correctness aside,
I'm going to use
this opportunity
to tell you that you have
been one of my biggest
celebrity crushes growing up.
Not only have been,
you still are.
Being a business graduate,
I think in matrices a lot.
So imagine, there's this matix
of an x-axis that shows you
the Greek godlike
looks of an actor,
and there is a y-axis
that shows you the--
ARJUN RAMPAL: Are we talking
Silicon Valley language?
I don't understand.
APRAJITA JAIN: No, no.
I'm just talking basic maths.
So let's say there's
looks over here
and superior acting skills here.
You'll find many
Bollywood stars that
are on the far bottom right--
great looking-- and you'll
find many that are on the left
corner there--
amazing acting skills, but
so-so in the looks department.
You for me are on
the up and the right
that covers both these areas.
So with this versatility
and you know,
being a fantastic actor as well
as jaw-droppingly good looking,
tell me a little
bit more about--
and we know a lot about it--
ARJUN RAMPAL: It sounds
like a great app, you know?
Just now, I mean, what she said.
APRAJITA JAIN: Like
Rate Your Actors?
ARJUN RAMPAL: The Crush App.
APRAJITA JAIN: No, but
tell me a little bit more
about how you moved from
modeling into acting,
and take us on that ramp.
ARJUN RAMPAL:
Yeah, so actually I
was going to be studying
finance and business.
And I was really into sports.
I was running 400 meters.
I ran state level.
And I really never
thought that I
would get into the
entertainment business
because nobody
from my family was.
In fact, they're more
from the army side.
Everybody wanted me
to join the army.
My dad didn't join the army, but
both my dadaji and nanaji both
were from the army,
very decorated.
So I did not think--
I was the only
boy, so obviously I
didn't think I had
any score or chances.
I loved watching the movies.
From when I was
a kid, I remember
I used to go watch the
movies first day, first show,
and then dressed like those
heroes for a little while.
But I didn't think that that
means that there's something--
that it's going to be
pulling me towards acting.
So one day I was at a nightclub.
And this designer saw me.
And he said, are you a model
and would you like to model?
So I thought he was
making a pass at me.
And I was like, no, sir.
No.
No interest in modeling.
But actually it turned
out to be a family friend.
His name was Rohit Bal, who is
now one of my closest friends.
And from there, I was
an economic student,
and economically it
made a lot of sense
to me that [INAUDIBLE] to go and
stand on or walk on the ramp,
or wear some very nice clothes.
It pays you a lot
more than I would
be getting paid by any bank
or any financial institute
that I'd be working for,
unless of course I owned it.
So from there-- and
I really enjoyed it.
From there, it kind of grew--
one thing grew into another.
I worked with wonderful people,
like Ashok Mehta, Skehar Kapur,
through my modeling
career, [INAUDIBLE],,
who kind of insisted
that I get into acting
and to the movie business.
Then I came to New York.
I wanted to study
filmmaking here
and enrolled in NYU film school.
But by the time
I went back home,
Ashok Mehta I had this film
called "Moksha," which I did.
And once I bit that
Apple, like Adam bit his,
I was completely taken
in into this industry.
And I'm really glad
that that happened.
So a lot of credit to Ashok-ji,
may his soul rest in peace.
He's not with us anymore.
But truly, from
there, Rajiv Rai,
all these people in the
beginning who really,
really helped me
from being a nobody
to reach wherever I reach.
APRAJITA JAIN: We are very
grateful to all these people
too, because otherwise
we wouldn't know you.
So thank you.
Now, the teaser is
back up, so let's watch
the teaser really
quick before we
jump into our next questions.
ARJUN RAMPAL: Oh, you
didn't see the teaser?
APRAJITA JAIN: There was
a technical glitch before.
ARJUN RAMPAL: At Google, hm.
APRAJITA JAIN: So we get
to watch it together.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[SPEAKING HINDI]
ARJUN RAMPAL: We
need some volume, no?
[SPEAKING HINDI]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
APRAJITA JAIN: Fantastic.
ARJUN RAMPAL: So that
was just a teaser,
but you'll get to
see a lot more.
APRAJITA JAIN: Just a teaser.
And I don't know if
I told everyone yet,
but Arjun is here
today officially
to unveil the theatrical
trailer of "Daddy,"
which we'll watch in just a
little bit together, right?
ARJUN RAMPAL: Yeah.
And you'll also get to know
when the film is releasing.
And so I thought it would be
kind of unique to come and do
it here, you know, because
obviously the digital medium
has gotten so huge right now.
And I had that opportunity
to come here and have
a talk with all of you.
So I said, it'd be a nice
way to just come and give you
my trailer.
We will do a big launch
in India, usually,
but we're doing it here
for the first time.
A lot of people ask me, why
are you launching a Hindi movie
thing at Google?
I was like, yeah,
Google is universal.
And you know-- and I
think it makes sense
because digitally I think
today everybody watches it.
And so you'll push this and
make it go completely viral
and make sure everybody is
going to go and watch "Daddy."
And excuse me,
technical, sir, [HINDI]..
APRAJITA JAIN: [HINDI].
ARJUN RAMPAL: Hi.
Can put the volume
a little higher
when you play the trailer?
Yeah?
Thank you.
OK.
APRAJITA JAIN: Great.
Fantastic.
So you have been one of the
most versatile Bollywood actors.
And you're going to show
us yet another facet
of your skill in this movie.
Tell us a little bit more
about how did this come about,
where did you get the
idea from, and why did you
go about making a movie about
a mobster in the first place?
ARJUN RAMPAL: Well, you see,
the first thing is, basically,
every gangsters--
I mean, every actor's
dream is really
to play a gangster at one
point in their lives, you know.
I'm sure a lot of your
boys will agree with me.
Do you agree with me,
a lot of you guys?
You like that
gangster film, right?
I mean, you want to
play that one gangster.
And there have been
so many gangster films
that have been made, like
"The Godfather," "Goodfellas,"
"Scarface," you know, "Satya,"
[INAUDIBLE],, "Company," really
good films that have come out.
And I was wondering,
now, who could I play?
And there were these
guys who came up
to me, who were producers
earlier on this film,
and they said, we'd like
you to play Arun Gawli.
Now, Arun Gawli, I said.
OK.
But what's the resemblance?
I mean, how do we
even look alike?
Because if you see Arun
Gawli, and please Google him,
you will know--
so once you know, it's
completely different,
the way we look.
But I started
reading up about him.
And I found his life
extremely intriguing.
And I found him a very reluctant
kind of a gangster, which
was very, very different.
It wasn't the gangster who
was going to be walking around
with all guns blazing.
He was a guy who used his mind.
He was a guy who went
through a journey, which--
from gangster, turned
into a politician,
was called the Robin Hood.
And what was the most
amazing part of it
was that people call him Daddy.
They don't call him by--
they don't call him Don.
They don't call him, you know--
you know, whatever,
other terms that you
use for gangsters in India.
They call him Daddy.
Why would somebody
call him Daddy?
Because he actually went
out there and looked
after a lot of people.
APRAJITA JAIN: Interesting.
ARJUN RAMPAL: But
at the same time,
we wanted not to make this film
a very propaganda kind of film.
But I was still not
impressed with the script
that came to me earlier.
So I kept rejecting
it, rejecting it,
but I got very upset with it.
And in that process
of my obsession,
I locked myself in a hotel
room for three months,
and I started
writing this story.
And suddenly the story
came about and got life.
And then I gave it to one
of my biggest critics,
who is the director
of this film, whose
name is Ashim Ahluwalia.
And he's a really, really
fantastic director.
He'd made this film called "Miss
Lovely," which did really well
in the Cannes,
indie film circuit.
He's extremely great
with detailing.
And everybody's asked him to
make a movie, and he said no.
So I gave him the script.
I said, he's going to rip it
apart because I don't know
if he'll-- you know?
And he read the script.
And he said, dude, I love it.
I'm doing it.
I said, but Ashim, I
don't want you to do it.
I was just asking you
to read the script.
I don't want you to direct it.
But he said, no, dude.
I'm doing the script.
I love it.
But we're going to tweak it.
So Ashim and me kind of
co-wrote it after that.
It was a long process.
Then we got the permissions
from the family.
We did a tremendous
amount of research.
See?
He took me to all
these crazy locations,
like you're seeing,
which are rat infested.
And I'll make a confession here.
I have-- I hate rats, OK?
I can fight a tiger, but if
you put a rat in front of me,
I will run away from that room.
So he's got this really
great aesthetic sense.
This is all his framing.
So it's-- and to create
that world, we needed Ashim.
And then we went out
there and we made it.
APRAJITA JAIN: And how was
Arun Gawli himself involved
in that process?
Did you meet him a lot?
Did you ask him about his
past life and what he did?
ARJUN RAMPAL: So, yes.
I did have the opportunity
to meet him a couple of times
when he came out on parole.
And of course met a
lot with the people
who are involved with
him, like the shooters,
the people who were part
of his gang at that time.
He's in prison now, so he
does come out on parole.
And he's a very, very--
what was really amazing
about him was that he is
not at all intimidating.
He is actually very humble.
APRAJITA JAIN:
He's Daddy, right?
ARJUN RAMPAL: Yeah.
And what's really amazing
about him is that--
they're very gentle.
And they have so many--
they're so well
mannered, you know?
They speak with a lot of
respect, what you call tehzeeb.
You know, they have a
lot of good manners.
They speak really, really well.
They're not-- they
don't raise their voice.
And it was amazing.
It was amazing to see that,
get that body language.
And one day we were
shooting in [INAUDIBLE]..
And he was also
out at that time,
so he was watching
a bit of the shoot.
So he was sitting like this
and I was sitting here,
and then he went away somewhere.
And it was really strange.
One of his relatives came out--
and I was dressed
like this, OK--
and came out and
touched my feet.
They thought it was--
so that was, I think,
the biggest compliment
that happened in [INAUDIBLE].
And so yeah.
There have been a lot
of great experiences
that have happened through here.
It's not been an easy
film to make, because we
wanted to keep it realistic.
We wanted not it
to be a propaganda
film, where you are
kind of glamorizing
a life of a gangster.
But we wanted to keep
it true to what it was.
We also believe that
there is a story out there
where somebody goes to jail,
serves his time, you know,
comes out, and we send
the person to jail
really to want that
person to reform.
But do we really
honestly as a society
give that person
a second chance?
That is something also you get
to explore through the film.
APRAJITA JAIN: Fantastic.
Well, you have really whet
our appetite about this movie,
about-- you talked
so much about it.
And we saw in the teaser that
your look is very different
as well in the movie.
So let's take this opportunity
to actually officially unveil
the trailer.
ARJUN RAMPAL: Yes, let's do
it, right here, for all of you.
APRAJITA JAIN: Have us
and everybody on YouTube
give us a chance to see it.
ARJUN RAMPAL: Yeah, let's do it.
And sound, volume up.
OK.
[FILM DIALOGUE IN HINDI]
[APPLAUSE]
APRAJITA JAIN: You don't
look anything like yourself
in this movie.
How did they do that?
How long did it take you
every day to look like this?
ARJUN RAMPAL: So yeah.
So we got these incredible
makeup artists from Italy--
Sergio, Simone, Ariana.
And it was five hours of
makeup every day in my trailer.
Yeah.
And I think I learned a
lot of Italian bad words
while going through it.
And yeah, so it was that.
And it was also a lot of the
aging process that happens,
because the film
starts in the '70s
and goes all the
way to 2012, 2013.
So it was a lot
of change in that.
But yeah.
And not just me.
I think every actor in this
film has gone through it.
Every actor had to go through
a lot of makeup, the styling,
you know, just to get
the body language right,
and to the clothes
and the costumes.
So it was very,
very interesting.
And I think it kind of
spoils you some way,
to be able to fit into
these kind of worlds.
And yeah.
APRAJITA JAIN: Very interesting.
Well, we don't only
have questions here,
but we also got a lot of
video questions for you--
ARJUN RAMPAL: Oh, wonderful.
APRAJITA JAIN: --from
all across the globe.
So we would love to give
you a glimpse into that
and give you the opportunity to
address those directly, coming
from the people on video.
So let's play our
first video question.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ARJUN RAMPAL: I don't lip read.
- --transport yourself back
to, because you had a lot of--
APRAJITA JAIN: Can
we restart that?
Thank you.
- Hi, Arjun.
This is Sanditi.
If you had a time machine,
to which of your past movies
making would you
transport yourself
back to because you had a
lot of fun acting in it?
[END PLAYBACK]
ARJUN RAMPAL: Oh, wow.
Which one would I--
I've enjoyed all my movies.
But one which I would
really like to go back to
would be "Rock On."
We had a lot of fun making that.
It was a great crew,
and it was great music.
And maybe I could go back
there and play the guitar
a little bit better.
APRAJITA JAIN: Did you actually
learn it for the movie?
ARJUN RAMPAL: Yes.
You have.
I mean, Abhishek
Kappor and Farhan
are very, very anal about all
of that, and being musicians--
a musician himself, it was very,
very critical that all of us
learned our instrument.
But I always wanted to learn
the guitar, so it was good.
APRAJITA JAIN: There you go.
Fantastic.
Well, talking about the
versatility of the roles
that you have played, and also
the different genres of movies
you have done--
right, normally, when
you think about Bollywood
stars, a lot of them
carve a niche for themselves.
They're known as Bollywood
chocolate actors or action
heroes or dancers.
And in the new
generation, these days
it's a little bit different.
They're more versatile.
They can do a little
bit of everything.
But honestly, you were
one of the first ones who
broke that mold and
decided to do everything,
from comedy in "Housefull"
to musical drama in "Rock
On," to thrillers in
"Aankhen" and "Ek Ajnabee"
to romantic movies--
you had "Pyaar Ishq Aur
Mohabbat," "Dil Ka Rishta,"
then you also did
"Raajneeti" and "Satyagraha,"
which are political dramas.
ARJUN RAMPAL: Yeah.
And a villain in "Om Shanti Om."
APRAJITA JAIN: Yeah,
you did a villain.
You were a cop in a movie.
Then now you're doing a
criminal turned a politician.
How do you go about
deciding which
roles you're going to take on?
And how do you
prepare for those?
ARJUN RAMPAL: You
know, actually,
one of my main criteria
of signing a film really
is that if I went out there
at the ticket counter,
and if I was not in this
movie, would I go and watch
this film regardless?
And that's the first question.
So that's the story.
APRAJITA JAIN: User first.
ARJUN RAMPAL: Huh?
That's how Google thinks too.
ARJUN RAMPAL: Yeah.
So you have to, you know, say,
would I really want to be--
would I watch it?
Then the second one
is who the people are
that you're associating with.
Then obviously what is the
graph that your character has?
And if it is just
one-dimensional,
I usually kind of
stay away from it.
But if it does have
layers and allows
me to explore a new
expression, a new body language
or allows me to bring anything
that would, A, surprise me,
which would then
surprise my audience,
is how I kind of like
to choose my work.
And there's very little
work like that that happens,
which would be only
based around you.
So it's good to experiment with
parts that you can do in films.
And then when you get
a film like "Daddy,"
you get a lot of
layers and you get
a lot of experience,
where you can put together
many, many layers together
through your experience.
So I guess, yeah,
that's how you do it.
I like to do it.
I get really bored
doing the same thing.
You know, if you tell
me to do the same thing
every single day, I
wouldn't be able to do it.
So if it is to work
out in the same way
or to go and meet the
same people everyday,
no, it doesn't happen with me.
APRAJITA JAIN: I
mean, it's easier
to keep doing the same thing
over and over again, but--
ARJUN RAMPAL: Yeah.
But I can't.
APRAJITA JAIN: --the
effort that you
put in in doing all
these different things,
it actually shows.
ARJUN RAMPAL: Yeah, thank you.
APRAJITA JAIN: Absolutely.
Now, we have a second
video question for you.
Let's roll that.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Hi, Arjun.
This is [INAUDIBLE].
So my question is,
in the recent years,
we have seen a lot of
Bollywood celebrities
doing Hollywood movies.
So, do we see Arjun
Rampal in Hollywood soon?
[END PLAYBACK]
ARJUN RAMPAL: OK.
If you get me a nice
agent, we'll talk about it.
But I don't know.
I guess, you know, it's great.
It's great.
I mean, you see so many
of our actors, especially
[INAUDIBLE],, who has
really come out there
and he's done some great work.
And now there's
Priyanka, Deepika,
everybody who's coming out
here as well and doing it.
So I think it would be nice.
They can take our
actresses, and we
can take theirs and
move them to Bollywood,
and make them act with us.
But it really depends,
again, I think,
borders are kind of diminishing.
And you know, everybody
is kind of interacting.
There's a big
audience out here who
likes to watch their own
actors in good parts,
in good mainstream
Hollywood films.
And so if something like that
does come across, why not?
But it has to be a really
good part, and something
which would make all of
you proud [INAUDIBLE]..
It wouldn't be that.
APRAJITA JAIN: I'm sure
we wouldn't say that.
Don't worry.
So let me come
back to the reason
why you were in the Bay
Area a few weeks ago.
You came to promote
a charity called CRY.
And I'm personally very
fond of causes that support
the betterment of children.
So tell us a little
bit more about CRY
and how you got
involved in that.
ARJUN RAMPAL: So, yes.
As a kid, my father
used to always insist,
if it was anybody's
birthday or if it
was Mother's Day, Father's
Day, you know, whatever,
to go and buy a CRY card.
Now, I had no clue
what this CRY card was,
so I used to buy
these CRY cards.
And they were really pretty.
And then as, you know, I
got a little successful
and I was on an aircraft
or something, you know,
you'd find this little envelope
which had a CRY envelope.
And so I just put
money in there.
And this went on for,
I think, a few decades.
And recently CRY
approached me, and they
said that they were doing
these gala events where they
wanted to raise these dinners.
I thought "Daddy" would have
released really, honestly,
by then.
So I was like, OK.
Fine, I'll come.
I'll come.
I'll do this.
But then "Daddy" got
pushed to the 21st of July.
And I had committed
to them a year ago.
But I saw the body of
work that they've done.
It's absolutely incredible.
You know, 18 million children
are out of school in India.
There are 30
million children who
get pushed into child labor.
There are 18.5
million children who
are pushed into child
marriage or sex trafficking.
And child really works
on grassroot level--
CRY really works on grassroot
levels to help these children.
And we went for these dinners,
and it was a superb success
from CRY America.
We raised half a million
dollars for all of them,
and that's really going to help
all these kids when we go back.
So yeah, it was great.
And I'm really,
really happy I did it.
And through that, I also
got to come to Google here.
So yes, it all comes
together nicely.
And this is where I end my trip.
I've been, I think, on--
I was just calculating
today in the shower.
It was, I think, 14
flights I've done in--
in 12 days.
That's what's happened.
APRAJITA JAIN: Yeah.
I know you've been flying back
and forth from the East Coast.
So thank you for coming
back just for today's event.
Really appreciate it.
ARJUN RAMPAL: Yeah.
Thank you.
APRAJITA JAIN: Now, CRY isn't
the only social responsibility
cause that you stand behind.
Due to some personal
experiences,
you actually started a charity
called the Gwen Beat Cancer
Foundation for cancer survivors.
Tell us a little bit more
about how that came about.
ARJUN RAMPAL: So Gwen
is the name of my mom.
She was three
years ago diagnosed
with breast cancer,
which got metastatic
and went into the lungs.
And so obviously, you know,
you want to do everything
for your mother.
And we came here to New York
and put her in the best hospital
there--
Sloan Kettering--
wonderful doctor,
Dr. Larry Norton, who
did the best that he
could with chemotherapy.
But chemotherapy really
takes its toll on your body.
And this was the
first experience
I was having with
anybody with cancer.
And through this process
I said, it's expensive.
You know, it is not cheap.
The drugs are really expensive.
In India, you don't have
those kind of insurances
that you guys have
out here as well.
But still, you know,
even the treatment
is very, very aggressive.
And it really amazes me
that we've got the internet,
we've got all of this,
we've gone to the moon,
you know, we've come back,
we've got satellites everywhere,
but we don't have
a cure for cancer.
And that really is kind of
baffling and not realistic.
So the chemo stopped working
for my mom at Sloan Kettering.
And I went to this
place [INAUDIBLE]
in Portugal, in
Lisbon, where there
was this doctor
called [INAUDIBLE],,
who does this thing called SDRT,
which is Single Dose Radiation
Treatment.
And it's a completely charity--
charitable organization.
It's a foundation.
You know, it's really
cheap for people
who are not part of Portugal.
So it's really, really
not that expensive.
And it was like a James
Bond kind of a set up.
You know, they made
a hologram of my mom.
They practiced how
to shoot this--
shoot this one shot in there.
It's not invasive.
And in 48 hours, three tumors
in her lungs were all gone,
and nobody knows about it.
So I really wanted to
bring this to people.
So I said, OK, we're going
to start this charity
organization, which will be--
it's actually the
Gwen Breast Cancer,
but we removed the R and
the S from the breast,
and it becomes beat cancer.
So that's how we've done it.
And I wanted to kind of promote
that so that more people get
to know about it, have
opportunities about it,
and we can kind of
bring more people--
get more people cured.
APRAJITA JAIN: Thank you
for standing behind that,
because people that have that
much of a reach on social media
and everywhere else,
they can definitely
play a big role in bringing
these type of awareness.
ARJUN RAMPAL: You
know, it's amazing.
It's amazing what's
happening there.
So you've got to support it.
Kind of, that's
what I wanted to do.
And that's something
which I support as well.
APRAJITA JAIN: Fantastic.
So let's shift gears
from reactive health care
to proactive health
a little bit.
We all know that you are
a fitness enthusiast,
and you've been
talking about it a lot.
But I also know that in the
making of "Daddy," you had to--
well, shall I put
it-- look human.
I'm just kidding.
You had to look like
a regular human being,
like somebody who doesn't
work out or who was a mobster
and didn't have all the bulk.
So how did that feel, not being
able to work out for so long?
And I'm sure it wasn't
a linear process.
You probably had to look a
certain way for some shots,
and then another way
for another shot.
So how do you--
ARJUN RAMPAL: Yeah,
because the film kind of
goes over so many
decades and yes, he's
not a bodybuilder, Arun Gawli.
I couldn't come with a
six pack and, you know,
muscles and all of that, or
else it would just make it--
it was tough.
I mean, I had not gone
to the gym for two years
through this process.
I had-- I just ran a lot.
And at some point, I
had to really be skinny.
And then when he
gets a little older,
Ashim wanted a little
more bulk on him.
So you know, I had to
then drink a lot of beers.
APRAJITA JAIN: Oh,
what a sad thing to be.
ARJUN RAMPAL: So, yes.
These two years, I lost a
lot of my muscle quality.
But now I'm getting
back into it slowly.
I need to get back to the gym.
I really missed it, and I
realized the value of health
because these last
two to three years
I don't think I've
been very healthy.
So yeah, it's good to get
back into the gym now.
APRAJITA JAIN: Awesome.
Any tips for us chair
potato Googlers?
We spend a good 10 hours
of our day in chairs.
ARJUN RAMPAL: Really?
10 hours in a chair?
APRAJITA JAIN: Pretty much.
ARJUN RAMPAL: Oh, no.
I don't envy you.
But no, I just
believe, if you look
at exercise just as a
necessity, as you need to eat
or you drink water or
breathe or rest and sleep,
look at exercise as well as a
necessity, and as your fuel,
that you're going to take
out the best de-stressor.
It's great for your
backside, which
you're going to be covering
so much on a chair.
But get your core strong.
Go out there.
Just do any form of
exercise for an hour
every day, 45 minutes, one hour.
It will change your life.
It will really, really
change your life
and do you a tremendous
amount of good.
And I think you all owe it to
each other and to yourselves.
And that's how I look at it.
APRAJITA JAIN: Good.
They say that a six pack of
abs is made in the kitchen,
and there are two
types of six packs that
can come out of that.
But tell us a little bit
more about your diet.
ARJUN RAMPAL: So yes, I eat
healthy when I'm training
and not being Arun Gawli.
So when I wake up
in the morning--
what, you want to know
everything that I eat?
APRAJITA JAIN: No,
but just like--
do you avoid certain things?
Do you really love
certain things
that we may think
is unhealthy, but it
doesn't make a difference?
ARJUN RAMPAL: It's
good to eat everything.
I don't think you should
become a fanatic about--
because that's a disease
as well, according to me,
because it's happened to me.
Where you say, OK, I want
to get really shredded.
I want, like, 5% body
fat, 4% body fat.
And then you kind of
get obsessive about it.
Anything obsessive is not good.
Anything excessive is not good.
So yes, if you want to shed
body fat, obviously you
lower your carb intake, take
a more high protein diet,
put more cardiovascular
into your exercise.
And as you lose it, then
start kind of taking the--
but you need carbs, you know?
You need carbs to
fuel your exercise.
So have good carbs.
There are good carbs.
There's good fats, like
avocado is a very good fat.
And you get great avocados
here in your region.
And have lots of fruits,
have lots of greens.
And being Indians, most of
you are vegetarians as well.
So greens are great.
I have good pulses, maybe
take a good protein shake
to get enough protein
intake inside of you.
But most importantly,
to eat like that,
you also have to work
out like that, you know?
Because you watch what you
eat, you control what you eat,
but also that food
has to be like fuel
that refules your workout.
So kind of just be aware.
But don't say no to everything.
We have great food, you know.
And enjoy it.
Enjoy it once a week.
Don't enjoy it every day.
APRAJITA JAIN:
Thanks for the tips.
We have lunch hour coming
up soon after that,
so I hope everybody
paid attention.
Now, you couldn't
have come to Google
and not expected
that you'd be asked
a question about technology.
ARJUN RAMPAL: Oh, god.
APRAJITA JAIN: Yeah.
ARJUN RAMPAL: OK.
APRAJITA JAIN: It's
not a hard one.
It's not a hard one.
In today's world,
where everything
has gone digital and especially
in the entertainment industry,
we know from our own
statistics that depending
on how well you promote a movie
digitally before its launch,
it can really impact the
launch week of the movie.
And I know we are
sitting right here,
using YouTube as a platform
to talk about "Daddy,"
but what else have you
been doing digitally
to promote your movies--
not only "Daddy,"
but any other movie
that you have produced?
ARJUN RAMPAL: I'm
totally relying on you.
No.
You do everything on Facebook.
You have Twitter.
You have Instagram.
You have so many
websites today, you
know, which promote your film,
like Bollywood Box Office
or different-- there are so
many different kinds of channels
that you can use.
There are lots of people
who create a lot of--
which we will be
doing, which make
a lot of these gigs and
programs around the film,
you know, which go viral.
And you know, youngsters
really like that,
rather than just talking
about the film, film,
film, to take the Mickey out
of the film as well is fun.
And if you can promote
it, the whole idea
is to get it as much
out there as possible.
So whatever the platforms
are digitally that you
can do it in you do it in.
Whatever we can
do as filmmakers,
which is to create and
give you content like this,
you know, which
we put out there,
is something which would
be exciting enough for them
to come in to watch it.
But yes, we need
all those platforms
to come together and help us.
APRAJITA JAIN: And
I saw you yesterday.
You were personally
sending out tweets and--
ARJUN RAMPAL: Yeah, I
do it personally myself,
and I get really irritated
that it's only 134 characters,
and how am I going
to get this in there.
And there's so much to say.
And you know, to do
it through Instagram.
And I was doing it on
Facebook, and then we got lost.
And I was like, OK,
guys, I got to go.
I'm not going to make this.
So I'm not very tech savvy.
But I think my kids are.
My kids are super--
APRAJITA JAIN: Do they help
you with the promotion?
ARJUN RAMPAL: Yeah.
They say, Dad,
what are you doing?
That's not a hashtag.
You've got to do this.
You've got to be cool.
You've got to be dope.
I say, what's dope?
Come on.
So yeah.
APRAJITA JAIN: Fantastic.
And out of all the
Google products
that you may have used,
which one would you say
is-- and I'm going to explain
a concept to you before that.
So there is this
thing at Google.
We call it the toothbrush test.
And a toothbrush test
means that every single one
of our products needs to be
used at least once a day,
ideally twice by people.
That's how we think about
coming out with our products.
So which of our
products would you
think serves as a
toothbrush to you?
ARJUN RAMPAL: It's
not a toothbrush.
It's like a towel for me, you
know what I mean, or clothes--
Google.
Everything-- I think your
search engines, you know,
the way you guys are,
your Google Maps--
I mean, it's genius.
I think the way it just kind
of connects everybody together,
you're in a foreign
place, you don't
know how to get from
one place to another.
And boom, you just put in an
address, it's right there.
APRAJITA JAIN: Fantastic.
So you do use our
products extensively.
ARJUN RAMPAL: I do.
I do.
APRAJITA JAIN: We're
glad to hear that.
We also have a live question
coming in right now,
because we are on live stream.
So does somebody want
to display the question?
Yes?
On my phone?
ARJUN RAMPAL: It's
on your phone?
APRAJITA JAIN: I don't
have my phone on me.
So if somebody wants to bring
me a phone, that would be great.
ARJUN RAMPAL: Ashim, do it.
There, Ashim.
Take your clothes off.
AUDIENCE: So these questions
came from your fans
on social media.
ARJUN RAMPAL: OK.
AUDIENCE: Who
watched your trailer.
So I'm just going to
read out the first one.
Any similarities between
Arun Gawli and Arjun Rampal?
ARJUN RAMPAL: In real life?
APRAJITA JAIN: Totally.
He was a mobster too.
ARJUN RAMPAL:
We're both daddies.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Here's another one
from your fans.
Which other real-life character
would you like to play?
Or have you thought
about playing, let's say.
ARJUN RAMPAL: Well, actually,
I'm toying with one script
right now.
But right now I
think I'm done with
a few real-life characters.
I want to do something
more fantasy.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Another one from your fans.
Is a movie with a
fictional script
more challenging or less
challenging than a biopic,
like you're doing with "Daddy"?
ARJUN RAMPAL: I think a biopic
definitely is more challenging,
because you are
restricted, and you
want to stay true to the story.
Fictional, you can just become
a pirate in the Caribbean,
and it's fine.
AUDIENCE: And this
last one, which I think
is a fantastic request.
Could you recite a dialogue
from the movie for us?
ARJUN RAMPAL: OK.
What should I say?
I don't know.
I think the dialogue that he
really uses in person also.
He says, [HINDI].
You know, that's what he does.
And the other one, which I
really like where he says, is--
actually, you know what
I would like to do,
is I would just like to play
a little game with all of you
out here instead of
saying my dialogues.
I want you to know some
lingo, like the gangsta lingo.
How you all say "dope" and
this, that, and I don't get it.
OK, I'm going to
ask you a few words.
[HINDI]
What does [HINDI] mean.
Does anybody know
what [HINDI] means?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ARJUN RAMPAL: Ah.
To give a nice tight slap.
So [HINDI].
APRAJITA JAIN: Thank god
you explained [INAUDIBLE]..
ARJUN RAMPAL: [HINDI].
[HINDI], what is a [HINDI]?
No, I know they're slippers.
But what does a gangster
say when he says--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ARJUN RAMPAL: Huh?
[HINDI]
[HINDI] means a gun.
A country-made gun.
Or English, [HINDI] means
a nice foreign gun, OK?
So there are words like this.
And I think what Google should
do is maybe create an app.
APRAJITA JAIN: Seriously.
That's important.
Next time I'm walking
around Bombay,
I don't want to be [HINDI].
Awesome.
One more question
for you, and this
is a little lesser
known fact about you.
So we talked about your modeling
career, your acting career,
your social engagements.
But you are also
an entrepreneur.
You opened a restaurant and
lounge in Delhi in 2009.
How did you get into that,
and where are you taking that?
ARJUN RAMPAL: Well, actually,
I really like to spin music.
I like electronic music.
I like deep house
and tech house.
And I think I'm a good DJ.
But my family didn't think so.
So I was like, OK, so if I
had to go and play this music,
where would I play?
And I thought, let me open
a nightclub, and let me go,
and I'm going to
go and spin there.
But I like music.
I like to promote such artists.
And I've always--
I'm a foodie.
So it's nice.
You know, you walk into
your own restaurant,
you have a little club, a lounge
bar, people enjoy themselves,
and I really wanted--
the first club that I
went to was in Delhi.
And when I went back to
Delhi when I became an actor,
nobody was going out.
People found it unsafe, and
the girls weren't going out.
And nothing was happening.
And when I opened
this place, once again
girls started coming out.
It was a really safe place.
And you know, it started
the business again.
And it was a
wonderful experience.
And we're going to do many more.
I love FNB.
I think it's really, really
great, if you can be--
I like hospitality.
I like people to come
there, enjoy a good meal,
feel safe, dress up nicely,
and then go home and be happy.
APRAJITA JAIN: So
when people go there,
are they likely to find
you there once in a while?
ARJUN RAMPAL: Yeah,
sometimes I do land up there.
I land up there quite
often, actually.
And now I'm opening one in
Dubai and one in Mumbai.
So yeah, it'll be fun.
APRAJITA JAIN: Great.
ARJUN RAMPAL: So come, anytime.
AUDIENCE: Where in Mumbai?
APRAJITA JAIN: Where in Mumbai?
ARJUN RAMPAL: [INAUDIBLE].
We're just locking the property.
[INAUDIBLE]
Please come.
APRAJITA JAIN: My next question
is a little quirky in nature,
just like the
person it is about.
So a few years ago we had
Lady Gaga here at Google,
doing a similar talk.
ARJUN RAMPAL: Oh, really?
APRAJITA JAIN: Yeah.
Today we have you here.
But there's more in common
to that than, you know,
both of you being here.
You actually hosted Lady
Gaga in India a while ago.
How did that happen?
ARJUN RAMPAL: So yes.
We were doing the
Formula, my club, the lap,
which was asked to do the
entertainment for the Formula
1, which came to India.
And they had this big budget.
And they said, we need
to get some artists down,
and they wanted me to do
the full entertainment
for the weekend.
And I was like, yeah, sure.
OK.
And I was very confused who
to get down as the artist.
And this is really,
really interesting.
So I'm sitting with my daughter.
And I asked her, I
was like, I don't
know, who should I get down?
And she said, Dad, get Lady Gag.
So I was like, who?
She said, Lady Gaga.
So I said, who-- you
don't know Lady Gaga?
OK, I'm sorry.
OK, so she showed me Lady Gaga.
And I'm sorry I'm
as ignorant as that.
And I really liked her.
I thought she had a great
attitude, a great vibe.
And I called this
friend of mine in LA,
and I asked him, dude,
is there a chance we can
get Lady Gaga for this thing?
And coincidentally,
she was coming down
to India at that time to
promote her "Monster" album.
And things happened, things
fell into place, and I must say,
she was really, really
a wonderful artist,
great person to meet, you
know, extremely humble,
loves children.
And she was supposed to
perform only for, I think,
15 minutes or 20
minutes, and she
did a full performance
of 45 minutes
because she enjoyed it so much.
APRAJITA JAIN: Wow.
And that was at your club?
ARJUN RAMPAL: Yeah, at the club.
And you know, it was really,
really a special event
that we did and
I think something
that Dehli will always remember.
APRAJITA JAIN: Great.
My next question
for you is really
about today's
political environment
and things that are going on
in general, including India.
What keeps you up at night
when you think through those?
ARJUN RAMPAL: What
keeps me up at night?
APRAJITA JAIN: Yeah.
Like, what are the
things that you
would like to change if you had
the means and time to do that?
ARJUN RAMPAL: Well, I think the
disparity is something which
really is of the biggest
concern, you know,
with the rich-rich and
then there's too much poor.
And I think to bridge
the gap between that.
I think women's safety today
is on everybody's mind.
I have two daughters.
I want India to be the safest
place in the world for women.
And I think that's
something which one really
needs to work towards.
It is.
And of course cleanliness.
You know, and I think
we all are working
towards that, [INAUDIBLE]
about it and everything.
We keep our homes
very clean, but I
don't know why we use the rest
of our country like a garbage
bin.
So I think a certain
amount of civic sense.
Education, education,
education--
if we can promote that and
educate people, you know,
I think India's got--
I love India.
It's so diverse.
It's got so many
wonderful cultures.
And if there can just be peace,
harmony, and these things taken
care of, and everybody
has a full stomach,
it would be great.
Yes.
APRAJITA JAIN: We have
an audience question?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So as a celebrity, you lead a
very glamorous and interesting
life.
So do you ever get used
to being a celebrity?
ARJUN RAMPAL: Glamorous
and interesting?
I don't know.
It looks glamorous and
interesting from there,
but really, it's--
I've been a
celebrity now, if you
can say it, for a long time.
It's been, I think--
I started modeling
when I was 17.
And I'm 44 now.
So what's that?
That's, like, 27 years.
And it's a long
time to be there.
And I don't think of
myself as a celebrity.
I think everybody's
kind of human, you know.
I have a certain
amount of power,
which as celebrity gives me,
to go and voice my opinions,
and to get certain things done,
like, for example, all of this.
But otherwise I like to lead my
life as normally as possible,
and I'm as normal as any one of
you out there, I promise you.
APRAJITA JAIN: Unless we have
any more audience questions,
I have one last one for you.
And we know we are
super-excited for July 21st
to see "Daddy," but
with everything that
takes a culmination
like that, I'm
sure you have other
things on the horizon,
projects you're thinking about.
So what's next in the life of
Arjun Rampal, professionally
or personally?
ARJUN RAMPAL: I
think I just want
to take a nice long
holiday after this one,
and write my new script,
and take off and maybe
come in this area.
It's nice and quiet.
And come here and
make lots of noise.
APRAJITA JAIN: That
noise is always welcome.
ARJUN RAMPAL: Yeah.
So yeah.
No, I think just take
it easy right now.
There's lots of
scripts that are there.
I have not had
time to read them.
I've been very
busy with "Daddy."
And so as soon as
this film releases,
I'll take some time off.
APRAJITA JAIN: Do you write
most of your own scripts?
Or do you--
ARJUN RAMPAL: No, this is--
I've started enjoying it.
It's nice to get involved
on a writing level
because it helps you as an
actor to really, really prepare
yourself well, you know?
Obviously the writing
is done by the pros.
You know, the dialogue
is given by all of them.
And you know, the
screenplay and all
of that-- you could
work towards it,
but I think the process is
wonderful to be a part of,
because it really, really
helps you understand
your characters really well.
APRAJITA JAIN: Yeah.
Fantastic.
With that, we wish you a ton
of success with the launch
of "Daddy," and--
ARJUN RAMPAL: Thank
you very much.
APRAJITA JAIN: I'm sure
everyone present here
and many people
on the live stream
are going to go
watch it on the 21st.
We will keep our fingers crossed
for this to be a great success.
And thank you again
for coming here.
ARJUN RAMPAL: Thank
you very much.
Thank you for having me.
APRAJITA JAIN: Spending
the time with us.
ARJUN RAMPAL: Thank you.
It's been wonderful.
Thank you, thank you,
thank you for having me.
APRAJITA JAIN: Thanks a lot.
[APPLAUSE]